Good training is a training that is allowing you to progress.
The thing is, how do you measure it?
What are the catches?
What kind of tools you need to be sure that you are stronger and faster next week?
I'm gonna show you this device.
This is dynamometer.
I'm gonna talk a little bit about that.
And I'm gonna talk about the most common mistakes you can do
to trick yourself that you actually progressing while you are not.
Okay, so let's start with the most common problem.
So you start to do exercise, whatever, let's say it's rising exercise.
Let's say you do it like that.
And when you have 10 kg, okay, this is your form.
12, 20, 25, 30, okay?
35.
It's changing your form.
So if you have exercise, if it's pronation exercise, right?
And for low weight, you set your standard to be here, but at some point you are pulling with slight rotation of your hand.
It's not the same exercise.
So you don't know how much you have cheated and how much you have progressed.
This is why
you need to have exercises that are measuring your strength, that are 100% strict, which is really hard to find, or you allow them to be cheated.
So this is good example for me when I decided I'm gonna go with cheated version.
So I thought that I would like to measure my fingers like that.
Well, the problem is,
I not even, I was thinking many things, right?
So I'm putting something here and then I'm squeezing it.
So if it fails, the lift is failed because it opened.
The differences were still there.
I even wanted to print like special handle to be able to put this block inside so it fits perfectly.
So I decided to go
fully cheated so i do something like that so i go there i choose i chosen the strongest position ever even if it's not optimal for arm wrestling even if it's not like 100 what i will do at the table but because i cannot cheat more i cannot lift more than in this position meaning if i'm lifting more in this exact position that i was lifting i'm overly stronger because i don't train
it like that aside of once a week, my tests, like max strength test.
I don't trade this hand position.
So if in this hand position that I don't train, I got stronger, there is like good chance that I got stronger also in different positions.
So this is the first thing about checking your maxes, checking your progress.
There's another thing with isometrics.
Isometrics are like the hot topic.
I've seen like many big channels are talking now about isometrics, meaning that isometrics are going mainstream, which is good, which is good.
Okay, so you have your isometric exercise.
Let's say it's elbow flexor exercise.
And you pull.
Well, first of all, when you do maxes,
you pull something the chances that you are doing really isometrics are low it's like overloaded eccentric most of the time so this is not isometric training what we call isometric but even if let's say you are able to some weight to keep the angle and then at some point when you are maxing out you are just going to eccentric phase you will not see
because when you are maxing you are maxing so you don't pay attention to this change of your you know position of your of your elbow and the thing is I caught myself actually while doing a similar lift to that by for for for rising so I actually saw that if I'm going full full out with you know this
eccentric phase to be really fast and strong, I can lift like a little bit more, like 200, 300, 500 grams more than I would do it otherwise.
So you need to also find exercises that are not allowing you for eccentric phase or you have to go all in, right?
Again, for, but
This is how easily... I mean, this is very similar situation to the first one, but I wanted to underline that because probably many people don't think about how easily isometrics are changing to eccentrics.
So, for example, you are trying to get your maximum voluntary contraction to estimate what is your 60% and you go your max, right?
And then you take 60% red.
No, no.
This is not how it works.
This is exactly how it doesn't work.
And that's why you are lifting too much comparing to what was tested in the studies.
Because in the studies, they checked real isometric contraction.
This is isometric contraction without eccentric phase.
And they check this and get 60% from this.
Not from this.
Okay?
Which you are...
absolutely unconscious that you are doing when you are maxing so like one rep max that what we believe is what what we call one rep max and maximum voluntary contraction that we see in the studies it's not exactly the same because we approach this in different way we we warm up nervous system it's warmed up this is not so in general these percentages in the studies like 60 of your
maximum so you are saying okay so i can lift 60 kilos so i'm taking like 60 of it it's it's less it will be less this is this is something that you need to figure out what it would be but it would be less okay so uh yeah the pulley systems the pulley systems at the gym when you are working out dynamically are completely different and i actually measured some
on this machine or any scale.
And first of all, they are fake.
And second thing, it depends if it's one to one, one to two, one to four.
You do not, you cannot compare your lifts with someone else or on other or different machines.
or with someone else that is posting something online and you try to replicate it, it just doesn't work.
So this is also a bad way to track your progress if you track your progress on different way of resistance.
So different machines, for example, different cable systems.
Okay.
This, I have quite a few of those.
Honestly, I'm gonna show you this one.
This is Tindec Progresor.
That is because the best, it was just one of the first one like available for the mortal people.
And that's why I got, I have different ones too.
Luckily there is, in this year you have a choice.
Like when I was buying this some time ago, it was literally the only thing on the market.
And now you have at least two Chinese companies that are doing dynamometers, like the cheap ones, cheaper than 250 euros.
This is what I call cheap.
In the United States, there will be a premiere of a new dynamometer, which is quite good by specs.
I'm going to tell you why and how.
I mean, it starts.
that there is more and more.
So these things are getting really accessible, which was not the case some time ago.
But yeah, that was one of the first ones.
So Tinted Progressor, this is version two.
Version one was ugly, but this one is nice.
And anyway, how do you, how to use this thing?
Well, actually it's pretty simple.
You put,
you put it on and you just pull, okay?
And you can measure few things with it, but let's say first it's application.
And whenever you attach it, you will know how strong you pull.
Why you need this instead of scale?
Because the scale showing you only the...
weight, the peak, which is not exactly what is important for armwrestling.
Only.
It is, but it's not only important.
So, we have this kind of device.
We have our exercise that is super strict.
I have here, for example, I have chain that I've measured exactly the length.
I put my forearm on the table.
The chain allows me
for some angle in my wrist and because it's pretty, you know, it's repeatable and then I'm just lifting my wrist and my forearm is not moving.
This is what I mean by strict exercise and this is like pretty strict, okay?
This is pretty strict.
I'm trying to build also a device that will allow me to put dynamometer here and just squeeze and that would be also strict, okay?
So this is the level of strictness that is like
not leaving any doubts and you can calculate your progress up to, you know, like 0 point something percent, let's say.
I don't know if I would call it study grade measurements, but they are close to, as close as it is possible in home setup.
These things are definitely not, so you need to figure out how to do it.
Maybe, maybe instead of this,
But yeah, you can measure progress, for example, using a yielding isometrics also, not max isometrics.
It's not very precise.
You will not know how much you get stronger, but you will see the trend.
And I was doing for quite a long time because I didn't have any other options.
So I have my weight and I lift it, okay?
And I add 100 grams to it.
Something like that.
I add 100 grams.
So if I lift 100...
grams I don't know how much how far away from my max I was but I know I lift more so next next next and I know that I wasn't lifting my max so I didn't know what my max is but I knew that I was pretty close to my max and my max also was growing with the weight added so not very precise way to measure your max
but you actually can see if you do progress on the lift using this method.
But this is not overcoming isometrics.
This is yielding isometrics, just like 95% plus of your one rep max.
But the thing is that sometimes you will add weight and you will fail at some point.
And you don't know that your strength didn't grow, stop growing, or you just,
went from 95, 96, 97, 98, and you hit your just max and that's it.
This is something that, this is the problem of it.
But this method in general works great unless you really have, you really need some precise measurement.
But let's go back to isometric training and dynamometers.
So dynamometers are gonna show you the peak, okay?
And the peak is your max strength.
and this same thing will show you the scale digital scale which you can say okay so i'm getting this scale but the problem is like a peak strength in arm wrestling it's not the most important thing i i know that most of you are just like no of course it is the strength is the most important and it's not it's not that that that's the big problem with understanding of arm wrestling so look you remember andrei pushkar his fights
where literally 500 milliseconds from go to pin, half a second.
So if you are in this position and you need one and a half second to reach your peak, you will never use it if you fight someone like Pushkar.
Because in one and a half seconds, he would pin you three times.
So what will matter
is what happened in this half second.
So if in half second, you can get only 40% of your max or 60% of your max, this is what matters.
And of course you can say, okay, but 500 seconds, all right, that's a long time, but this is from the go to the pin.
So what really matters, what is happening in 100 milliseconds, because actually it changes if you are here.
or you are here, right?
Here or here.
And this is not maximal strength that decide if you are here or here.
I'm slow, so I feel it every time.
I feel it badly, okay?
So it's like 100 milliseconds and you are here.
How much stronger you have to be to be able to catch someone in this position?
And 200 milliseconds, you are here.
300 milliseconds, you are like that, okay?
That's why we need this thing instead of scales.
Because you can measure how fast your strength is growing.
So for example, you do your measurement, boom, okay, and you check at 100 milliseconds what I got, at 200 milliseconds what I got, at 300 milliseconds what was my result.
And this is the way
that even if your max strength is not progressing, you see, okay, but I'm faster on 300 milliseconds or 200 milliseconds.
Okay, so that's great, but I'm not faster at 100 milliseconds, so I need to find something to make me faster at this, at the goal at 100 milliseconds.
Because you might get stronger overly while not getting those,
low you know the the first milliseconds improved and so what you are lifting way more but to get you contracted all the muscles you need like one and a half seconds or two seconds doesn't matter it doesn't matter if you lift five kilos one kilo ten kilos more if you can't use it in the fight so this is called rate of force development and dynamometers are made for this and
Of course, ThinDeck Progressor doesn't have enough sample rate to measure it with great success, because it has 80 measurements per second, which is definitely too small.
In studies, in general, we use from 500 to 1000 samples per second.
But as I said, I didn't have choice back then.
And now, for example, this one is already 160 samples per second.
And you can buy, you will be able to buy soon the ones that cost around $100 and will have around 500 samples per second, which is great.
But in general, I believe that even if device is not precise enough to do the study, if you
do same setup on the same device and you see progress then it's then it's okay even if it's not gonna be like perfectly um perfectly uh let's say uh scientifically correct because you might miss on some data so this is something that make a division between scales and dynamometers okay that's why you need dynamometer instead of scale because scale is not giving you
full picture so to sum it up you need very strict exercise the exercise that you are testing doesn't has to be the one you're training okay so it can be something else you need to have you need to maintain form you need to avoid for any cause eccentric or you need to design the exercise the way that eccentrics are part of it you need to do it
on same machine or in the same setup, preferably you are using this to make sure that everything is right and what you are measuring is not only your strength, but also how fast your muscle contraction was.
So yeah, I wanted to make a short video and I think I've touched too many subjects that I will have to develop in future, but
It is what it is.
Bye.